vancouver unfortunately i have to
reschedule there's a lot that goes on to
getting in and out of our countries and
until that's a little easier
i'm gonna have to postpone the vancouver
and the edmonton shows
um but
thursday march 3rd i will be at zany's
for one night only and friday march 4th
and saturday march 5th i'll be in
lexington get all your tickets at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media uh look i want to thank you
for your support the show continues to
grow because of you and i cannot thank
you enough so if you're watching the
show please hit that subscribe button
right there uh and subscribe all right
it helps the show it's a free way and it
really does mean a lot to us the patreon
again another show that continues to
grow every month i think man i haven't
can't can't possibly hear some new [ __ ]
and you guys
never let us down the patreon is called
the honeydew with y'all it's five bucks
a month if you sign up for a year you're
getting over a month free all right you
get the honeydew a day early ad free at
no additional cost and if you or someone
you know has that story that has to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com alright
hopefully we get to do an episode
together i say it every week we've
talked to the wildest people wildest
stories from people who have died from
people who've been abandoned and uh
paralyzed in the wilderness people who
just now meeting their biological
parents i mean
death
uh what we had to i always say the girl
with two [ __ ] two [ __ ] came back
one [ __ ] okay we're doing [ __ ] over
here changing lives all right that's
what's going on with the honey do y'all
now the night pants nation tour
continues to roll uh get your tickets at
ryan sickler.com march 3rd one night
only i'll be in zaney's nashville march
4th and 5th i'm in lexington kentucky
again all tickets are available at
ryansickler.com now you guys know what
we do over here we highlight the low
lights these are the stories behind the
storytellers today's guest i'm beyond
excited and thrilled to have on here
first time on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome tony hawk
welcome to the honeydew today thank you
very much
dude
16 year old me 48 year old me all of me
is freaking out i appreciate it for real
thank you i'm gonna say this to you
i said it to you before we began but
in the 10 11 years i've been podcasting
you have been the most
professional
easiest to deal with kind you've been
like hey i can't do this but i can do
this i'll let you know on this we get
people who come on and record and then
want to cancel it show up day of cancel
never mind it's the comedians are the
biggest pain in the ass and you are the
one person
in my opinion who could act like a diva
if you wanted to you've earned the right
and you are the kindest nicest person so
thank you tony hawk for being a breeze
to deal with i think it's well for one
it stems from being on the other side of
it because now we are podcasting i had a
radio show on siriusxm for 10 years so
uh no almost 15 years um but
i know the other side of that and so i
know that
it's so frustrating on the other side
and it also just feels it it feels
insulting when people just
go ghost you ghost you yeah ghost you
when you've and
it wasn't easy
i mean just in terms of the radio show a
lot of times i was setting up interviews
at their siriusxm studios in la i'd have
to drive up here from san diego and then
someone's like i can't do it yes
you're like huh i can't cancer
today like what yeah i know i fell down
the [ __ ] steps this morning i know
that's right um but but at you know at
the same time
this is what you know what you get i'm
not i'm not
you know i'm not working through a bunch
of agents and pr people yeah that's what
i'm saying no agent no pr part you've
been dealing with us so thank you um all
right so there's a million things i want
to talk to you about but before we do
please plug promote everything you'd
like
oh
i'm never prepared for that um well you
got a great news right now skateboarders
birdhouse skateboards is my my uh
my baby we're 30 years old um this year
so that's exciting and and we still you
know going strong we had a good team um
yeah hawk vs wolf is podcast with jason
ellis um we're having a blast doing that
every week and getting really it's great
it really is great yeah i would say if
i'm going to plug anything
um it's weird to be plugging it but uh
sam jones did a documentary about my
career
uh called until the wheels fall off and
that is coming to hbo
i think in april all right i haven't
officially i've
i've gotten
i've gotten uh some dates but i don't
know exactly which date is the real one
yet but i think it's an april dude
that's a great title i'm [ __ ] stoked
for that thank you sam i think um i i'm
i don't think i would have wanted to
deal with anyone else but sam because he
really has a very soulful approach to it
have you seen it did you see the [ __ ] i
saw a very very early rough cut and the
only reason i saw it was not to control
the narrative of it but just to
um be more factual
you know to
to be like a fact checker
um and and to make sure that the footage
is legit because
there's a lot of footage out there from
old skate parks and stuff and
sometimes you don't know who shot it or
who's in it
so you got all that stuff over the years
um he found he did he found some nuggets
yeah did he find any stuff where you're
like holy [ __ ] yeah where'd you get this
absolutely yes hell yeah yeah what's
that feel like
it's weird because
in the age of the new media it feels
like everything has been uncovered
or documented and so
it's hard to believe that there's just
stuff that's been sitting
on a tape in a storage you know that
yeah no one
that no one either
either they forgot about it or they
didn't kid they don't care about it and
it's like this stuff is golden it's
amazing
well i know like again as a kid like you
it's i want to say this people always
say the michael jordan of they even say
is tony hawk to michael jordan of
skating but look i'm i'm sincere when i
say this i think we need to change that
term to the tony hawk of you're how old
now 53 you're 53 you're still out there
skating against teenagers you're still
doing the damn thing michael jordan all
respect the mjs i haven't seen him do a
[ __ ] layup in the nba you're still
out there and skating is a million more
times dangerous than basketball like at
any moment doing the [ __ ] you do you
could be paralyzed
every single time i mean
that's that's definitely a theme of this
documentary that i was talking about but
um
hey i'm just honored if anyone even
speaks my name in the same sentence as
michael jordan's [ __ ] that you
also you michael jordan may may have
saved a league that that already existed
but skateboarding
was like i was the kid that i was
telling you i i skated to your house i
wasn't rail sliding and [ __ ] up and
down on ramps my buddy matt schilling's
dad built a half pipe in his backyard
and they all would drop it and i just
remember looking at it like
nah i know i i'm not that graceful
enough
and
you know
whenever your board would drop we would
go to white marsh mall and it was the
one place that had like a skate shop and
we would just stare at that because we
couldn't afford that board you know what
i mean and we're looking at it and then
our friends would start getting and
everything we got to cut grass we got to
sell our candy money and like oh my god
so
you
you have so many accolades i looked some
stuff up and there was some interesting
stuff and i want to ask you genuinely if
it's true i know i asked you this one
already but i i read that you have
a roller coaster named after i did yes
where where was this uh six flags out
here um it was uh they had two of these
roller coasters one was in st louis and
i believe the other one is in san
antonio is there san antonio six flags
probably it's a criminal that i don't
know that but um is that but are they
still there
no well
here's here's how it all played out six
flags wanted our tour we did this boom
boom jam tour which was uh skateboarding
bmx and motocross as entertainment as a
show
and they wanted us to do this tour that
we used to do in arenas and bring it to
their parks
so we did this sort of scaled-down
version that we could do outdoors of the
same show
and they said well we
in that same deal we want to do a
licensing thing with you to
to brand a ride because they just had
this new ride that they were working on
so it was all together and so it was
called tony hawk's big spin and
basically
four people sat in a cart and and the
cart spun around as it went around the
track it was super cool it was fun
and i added
my
aesthetics to it graphics things it they
made little cars look like skateboards
oh that's cool it was cool yeah um i got
to ride my mom she passed away but but
she was i think she was 80 when when we
did that deal she came out to the grand
opening and i wrote it with her no she
was 80. how awesome is that it was
pretty cool that's badass oh my god
and so
then six flags went through a bunch of
changes
um
i think they might have even were
in in at risk of bankruptcy there was a
lot of weird stuff going on
so
basically that ended our deal
you know and
uh because that there was no more
agreement between us they had to rebrand
the roller coaster so i think those
roller coasters are still there i don't
know what they're called now it's not
the tony hall it's not experience or
whatever i'm sure i'm sure if you scrape
off some paint you can see that the
wheels are still there on the bottom
still got those skateboard wheels
all right here's another one i was
interested about too
it i read this you struck out in
baseball and you had to be physically
coaxed out of a ravine or something yeah
yeah
that's just like the cliche bad news
bears scene yeah but what was that all
about um
were you just were you strong-minded
that's that would be that that would be
the um
candy-coated term my mom would use
probably
uh stubborn for sure i think it was more
that
when i when i went to go play baseball i
i didn't consider losing or or the
the effects of losing of because i just
thought i'm going to go play baseball
i'm going to come up to bat and i'm
going to hit a home run like that there
was no
other option right and then i struck out
and i was like what what is this no one
prepared me for this scenario i mean i
was eight or nine maybe
and then i just ran because i felt like
i disappointed well my dad who was
helping to coach the team but i also
felt like i just disappointed the whole
team
and that shame
was overwhelming and i just
went ahead
and it was like you're not gonna you're
not gonna pull me back out because i'm
just gonna screw it up for everyone
again it's really interesting you say
that you're right because you are only
eight or nine and it's to be expected at
some point but no one can ever
prepare you for what what it's gonna how
your body's gonna process failure and
yep yeah that's interesting so they had
to get you did you finish the game or
were you like nah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i think that
yeah good question
i think i think that i was i was way
more um
hesitant to swing after that and it
probably i just got walked the next bat
were you good at sports i was okay i was
just really small so
i was pretty good and how tall are you
right now i'm 6'3 but yeah but when i
was young i was really small and super
skinny i mean i was like the
you know i was the typical like little
kid everyone's bullying because i looked
like i was two grades lower than i
should be i mean i looked like you know
i was two grades lower than i was in and
then um i played baseball i was short
stop i i did okay like
i um
you know i would get on base and i'd
make plays and stuff but it wasn't
outstanding
and then i played basketball and i was
pretty scrappy in basketball because i
wasn't afraid to get hurt
so i was a good player but i but i
wasn't tall enough to really make
baskets that much so i'd finally get i'd
get to the hoop and then
i'd miss
let's see here right there you know like
i'm from i'm free and clear of everyone
i got the ball just like
and so um but i did i did pretty well
like my second season of of playing
basketball i made the
whatever the
art areas all stars
um
and then i was i was then baseball
season come back in
and
i started skating around age 10
and as i started skating and really
diving into
what was possible and and how to do
things and and the the
the professionals
it was like
this is it this is what i want to do and
i really i had to tell my dad that i
don't want to play baseball anymore the
the very season that they appointed him
president of the little league
no halfway through the season
romanticizing it but i'm pretty sure
that
i i know that that my mom came to pull
me out of the skate park to go to
baseball practice so she came to pick me
up i was like no i'm trying to i'm
trying this trick i'm trying to stretch
she's like you've gotta go
baseball practice and then i went
reluctantly just super stewing the whole
time and then when i got to baseball
practice i i decided right then and
there that i was going to tell my dad i
don't want to play anymore i still have
my knee pads on from the skate park yeah
yeah walking up in defiance
[Laughter]
but to his credit
he he supported me and and finished out
the year as the little league president
teddy good for him yeah he did one term
just one skate park yeah you're not set
up he has no kid play he's probably the
only president's last coach
he was older when i was he was older
when i was born so he was like grandpa
oh really at the house
uh he was 45. okay he's older than me i
was 41. i always think about that too
like if they're gonna be like hey is
that your grandpa your graduation like
no you little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then people always thought my
siblings were my parents
oh really yeah
all right we're gonna go through a
couple more of these and then we're
gonna go
talk about how it all got started all
right
by the way iq of 144.
i don't know if that's still valid but
well you haven't
i had a good run with it numbers are
numbers
that's don't lie
all right uh 1999 first skateboard uh
first your first person to land a 900
right yeah and then 2011 you did it
again at 43.
uh
20 uh 18
at 43 yeah okay that thing's that's
google
and then but this is math but didn't you
do it again at 48.
oh oh at 43 yes you're right 20 sorry
i'm i thought you were jumping in that
one yes so you've done three of them no
i've done it i've done it a bunch a
bunch yeah but the le the last i did
i did it almost every other night
for like 30 shows yeah
it was it's hard because the the trick
is really what's really dangerous but
it's also kind of it has to happen
organically
it's hard for me to plan it
and so in those tours when
things were when i felt like i was on
point i felt like i was loose i would
just try to do it and then i would see
it through you were never like okay i'm
gonna go do this now and skate if i sit
if i set out to do it it was much harder
to
uh to get there
and sometimes not at all
and at 48 is the last time you did that
yeah it was because i was uh i'm 48
right now listen man i hold on to rail
going down the stairs okay for real
48 michael jordan's not out there
playing basketball at 40 [ __ ] eight
you're doing a 900 at 40. that's two and
a half turns right is my math correct
yes on a skateboard that you land that
you land
and at 48 years old dude you're [ __ ]
amazing
thank you
and then okay also
you skated at the white house
um i did i uh i got invited uh it was
during the obama administration i got
invited to be there for a father's day
event where they were trying to
uh advocate for
fathers being present and being involved
in their kids lives and they had a bunch
of um different
athletes and tv personalities musicians
and and stuff that were fathers and they
were all sort of they were visiting the
white house they had a big event and
then they would fan out to different
charity projects around dc to go visit
and talk to people but
i went and i brought my skateboard
because
everywhere i go if i don't have my
skateboard people say where's your
skateboard
it's just they just expect and like just
do they expect tom brady just holding
football
it's just this thing that they expect me
or that like did you skate here
and so i went to the country and so i
did i just brought it because i just
thought i'm not gonna be caught the
white house with my skateboard and then
at some point did you have the thought i
didn't think of that before never and
then at some point
i was looking around
and no one's around i mean i know
they're watching you obviously cameras
everywhere but but i had a um i had a
dude that was that was sort of my escort
tour guide through you know
or just making sure everything is cool
and
i was like can you shoot a photo of me
if i skate now he's like i can't i can't
do that and this other athlete came up
um i think he was a basketball player
came up behind him and i was like dude
shoot this photo and just skated down
the hall and he shot it and then i put
it out there and
caused a
stir [ __ ] you've done more for your
sport than any other athlete has done
for their sport
i don't know if that's doing something
for the sport but i was celebrating i
mean for me i was celebrating why i got
there sure and and just the idea that
i i wrote a skateboard and and that
brought me to an invitation of the white
house like that's amazing isn't it um
and people you know there was all this
weird
there
haters were like you're disrespecting
our house and it was like
i've rolled you're waiting for more
years guys
just wait a few more years if you think
this is disrespectful
i wasn't doing nada spins on george
washington's bust or anything
no one's storming anything settle down
guys
if you have multiple credit card
balances each month and you're only
paying the minimums barely making a dent
in your credit card debt it can be
discouraging upstart can help you pay
off your existing debt quickly so you
can feel like you're finally getting
ahead whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in just five minutes for loans between a
thousand all the way up to fifty
thousand dollars and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew today's program is brought to
you by athletic greens the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
really simple with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive busy schedules poor sleep
exercise the environment work stress or
simply not eating enough of the right
foods can leave us deficient in key
nutritional areas look i'm guilty of all
that all right not eating well not
exercising all the time
busy schedule just going for the easy
thing sometimes and ag-1 is part of my
morning routine now now i just take it
every morning when i get up and one
tasty scoop of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food-sourced
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving join the movement of athletes
moms dads rookies first-timers and
everyone in between taking ownership of
their daily health and focusing on the
nutritional products they really need in
the simplest manner possible to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com honeydew
to take control of your health and give
a g one a try now let's get back to the
do man skate i mean how old do you feel
on a given day like where are you when
you're on your board does it do you
transport to a time do you feel ageless
do you feel like like because i still
feel like
i don't know i feel like 25 26 but the
rest of my body is like [ __ ]
um
i feel i feel the same mentally for sure
um i mean i've learned a lot and and
learned how to process things better but
physically
it just things get tight that's what i
noticed but but i've never i've never
taken a big break from skateboarding so
i feel like that's my secret is that i'm
always sort of
i'm always in the in the mode and i can
just go like i went to my ramp yesterday
drop in and i know i've got this warm-up
routine that i can do and that sort of
tests how i'm feeling that day and what
maybe i need to work on but there are
days when i get there and i my body's
just really stiff
and i push through it
but i can feel it for sure and my neck
is like i've had so many whiplashes
through the years my neck is super stiff
and so that's the thing people notice
usually physically like what's wrong
with your neck like
what's not wrong with my neck
yeah what is not wrong 40 years
we call we call it chicken neck is when
you when you
come down the ramp but you're kind of in
the back seat and then you end up
shooting out when the flat and then you
get [ __ ] you get this sort of
click in your neck and you know it's
gonna be a bad day the next day um
what
all right let's go let's do this this is
what i want to do i wanted to just do
some of the stuff off the top let's go
back to the beginning because obviously
this road hasn't always been a smooth
path it's not for anyone especially
someone at your level there's
all the bumps and bruises in between so
i want to talk about you say at 10 you
quit baseball basically to start skating
that's where it really yeah um
right now though what do you do
physically to to maintain your health
yeah that's it there's no yoga no what
do you do to stay stretched and loose
skate just sit yeah that's it i love
that i yeah i mean i know there is a
part of me that thinks
with the stiffness i could benefit from
doing this yoga and stuff like that i've
just never had the patience
yeah to to get to do go do something
else um i do have uh i get body work
done on my neck mostly um by a guy who
does chiropractic and also does sort of
um asian medicine and stuff and and
he's helped me immensely over the last
five years do the y strap or they yank
your neck out like rock em sock em
robots none of that stuff oh it's so
good no he doesn't uh he mostly just
works on on right here and acupuncture
and
um
like yesterday i went to him in the
morning went to my ramp learned new
trick
so yeah i mean i guess there's nothing
that could really prepare you for the
crash of a an epic skateboard fall like
that like what could you really be doing
that like oh this works
um
yeah i guess i don't i never anticipate
falling
um i know the i know the possibility is
always there
and i've learned to
take falls obviously and and sometimes
i've learned to
to
fall
safer than
than people would expect
from great heights if that makes sense
yeah that's the other thing i was
telling else like not only do you guys
have to learn your trick but you have to
learn how to crash i see i was at x
games a few years back in minneapolis
and i'm watching these guys literally
fly and they know they're not going to
make it so they'll bail the board but
then they gracefully hit their knees and
slide i'm like that's you have to learn
how to do that yeah you have to that's a
that's a you have to learn how to make a
mistake
when people want to learn how to skate
vert ramps that's usually the first
thing i'm showing them is how to take a
knee slide
because that is what's going to get them
out of of a situation safely and that's
not the same
you know skating has all kinds of
disciplines and styles and so street
skating isn't
of of that nature where you're not going
to be sliding on your knees jumping down
10 stairs
but in the case of of ramps and pools
and stuff that is the way and so that's
what we you know it's kind of strange
it's something that happened organically
through the years that we were trying to
figure out who was the first
person to knee slide and oh really yeah
that's a tough one because knee pads
went from volleyball pads
and then they got a little bit more um
a little bit more padded and a little
bit more
advanced but it wasn't until someone put
a plastic cap on it that we realized oh
we can just slide on our knees yeah yeah
i've read before that playing in the nfl
is equivalent to like a car wreck a week
i've read somewhere that rodeo cowboys
their their average career between
injuries is maybe eight weeks before
they're you know pop and arm or whatever
like how how often what's the longest
time from an injury you've ever taken
off from skating
uh about two months i broke my pelvis
and that was
i mean if you want to talk about low
lights that was probably one of the
lowest times of
not my career but but my my life and my
motivation because
that seemed like it could have been a
career ender how were you
um
good question uh i think i was 38. and
where were you 36. um i was at bob
bernquist's ramp
shooting an episode of wild boys oh okay
um and i'm on the show so this is
yeah
yeah this one episode
the the well we we had all the skating
done before i got hurt for the most part
for what they needed so it's it's in the
the episode is is done like we're in it
and you wouldn't know any better if you
watched it
um but thankfully jeff tremaine who's
the director of jackass and and wild
boys and and uh he he locked the footage
away
and didn't ever even really acknowledge
it that was for my benefit
um and it wasn't until years later
when i had finally recovered and
mtv was doing scarred
the show scar was like what's your worst
injury and they hit me up and i said
they said what's your worst interview
well it was shooting for you guys no
[ __ ] and they didn't even know right and
i said well you got to talk to tremaine
and jermaine give it to him so it's
there but um basically
we had just come off i mean it was like
two days after
our hak jam tour that we did 30 shows
across the country
um on our ramp we had we had one of
those big air mega ramps yeah jumps in
the show we had a loop in the show
every night right we were doing this and
um
bob told me hey the wild boy is going to
come to my house because they have a
i think there's an orangutan that skates
and so they're going to of course
they're going to bring the orangutan and
he's going to skate my ramp and then
they want they want
me to dress up in a monkey suit and
we'll skate with orangutan i was like
that sounds awesome because i've been on
tour for five weeks i'll bring my kids
they can see the monk you know
the primate and uh
that's super cool right and so i brought
my kids i brought my friend to you
because my kids were really young then
um they were like
six and four maybe
and i knew i was gonna be skating so
we did the thing the rank tank it was
amazing um i mean he really did like
he's really skated yeah he didn't like
it if he got ahead of him though because
he got ahead of him he would jump off
and come out after you
for real when did you realize i saw i
saw that happen to bob
cause bob was skating with it first and
he got ahead and i was like
[ __ ] with it
yeah oh yeah yeah
so then we dress up in our monkey suits
and we do a routine like a doubles
routine that we had done
in all the nights of the huck jam
and then at some point bob has this loop
at his house his loop is super rickety
it's old it's outdoors it's wood
it's it's not the quality of the one
that we were doing on the tour
but in our excitement we said
monkey loop let's do the loop yeah woo
and so
we go over to his loop
and
i should have known right at this moment
but bob dropped in
and went around and fell he didn't fall
hard but he fell on his way out
that's bob's own personal loop right
that he can't make in this moment yeah
right
and we've been doing like i said we've
been doing it
on our show every night and so i'm
thinking you know just just for it i
went around and fell on the way out too
because it was so it was so weathered
that it was slow
and the first rule of doing loops is do
not pump your legs all the way through
that's that's it like if
anyone listening wanna do a loop here's
the secret you you hold it for a half a
pump because it's not a trick it's
actually a
a ride a momentum thing isn't it it's
it's like
it's like you know when you ride a
roller coaster and you go all the way
around you never know the moment you're
exactly upside down
you know what i mean because there's so
there's so much it's all the inertia
that's holding you to the track it's
like that but you have to have the
perfect amount of speed and the perfect
amount of pressure on your legs pushing
the board into the wall if you let your
legs extend you got nowhere to go and
you come off so you're always going that
you're pressing in you're always
pressing in like sort of halfway but you
need the right amount of speed to do
that bob's starting ramp was was not
steep enough
um to get that amount of speed with how
weathered the ramp was that's that's the
key
so
in my infinite wisdom
my next turn i dropped in and i pumped
going into the into the loop
full extension on my legs
and that's it that's the kiss of death
so so i'm spinning in the air as i'm
going upward so i actually i actually
spun up to the top and then kept
spinning and landed on the ground
you broke your pelvis in a gorilla suit
yeah
broke my pelvis right this thumbs up the
you
orange
me the finger like that's what you get
uh i don't remember much after that
i was i was out cold you really knocked
you out yeah i was out fracturing my
skull right here oh holy [ __ ] yeah
um and fractured my skull fractured my
thumb broke my pelvis
i woke up like
i've had
concussions in the past so i know
you know i sort of know the feeling and
the protocol of it i came to
even though i was probably talking and
whatnot but i came to like fully
mentally when they were putting me in
the ambulance because
it hurt so much as they moved me
in my hip that that's kind of what
shocked me awake and i said
oh something is wrong with my hip and
they said i will x-ray it
you know they they were just kind of
playing it down and i remember saying
where are my kids they said oh your
friend already took them home and
luckily they were on the other side of
the ramp they didn't see me fall good
yeah they just knew something had
happened so he took them home and um
and uh basically i spent
i spent about six weeks just sitting in
bed
um because there wasn't much they it
wasn't like they needed to fuse it
together or anything that it was it was
still in line so they just let it heal
i let it heal and then uh
played a lot of video games
during that time are you good at your
video game uh yeah are you good at your
game are you yeah but i was i i i we
were between games at the time so i
played um
okay did you ever play that game i
haven't though
loosely based on deadwood
i love deadwood yeah really cool game
and i you're a deadwood fan yeah oh
that's shakespeare on television man
that was so fun when they took that one
i love deadwood
uh my brother actually got to uh work on
that a little bit oh really yeah with
david milch um because he's a writer
so uh
but but in that time
and i know i
i gave you the long version of how i got
hurt in that time
was when i really had to dig deep
because i felt like i lost my identity
everything that all my success my
everything i did was based on my
physical act of skating up to that point
in my life and that was just
taken away
of my own doing but
gone
and i didn't know if i could make it
back a hundred percent i had no idea i
had no idea if i would even be able to
to is that where your mind is that where
your mind's going you're worried if
you're ever going to be able to skate
again
like what happens to your career
it was it was more evident when i
finally was starting to move around and
get up
because
that's when [ __ ] got real because i
couldn't put any weight on my leg and i
was trying to pretend that i'm just
gonna
push through this
and you know there's there's a point
where you're a skater you kind of learn
to live with injuries or or some sort of
of of um
issue
where you you compensate for it but you
figure it out this was not
of that nature this was like i
physically can't walk or if i'm walking
after
10 minutes i'm i'm severely limping
and so that's when it was like how am i
ever going to skate again and um
we had an
exhibition scheduled for two months out
in orlando
and i just made that my goal
i am i'm gonna i'm gonna skate two
months it was three months after my
injury but but once i started walking it
was like what was the full extent of
your injuries broken pelvis anything
else did you have any
uh
no
obviously your concussion yeah you said
it crack it cracked you here too
yeah fractured skull fractured
jesus and you're gonna try to do this in
two months
yeah i mean three months from the injury
and so but that was the goal and that's
what i needed
and i needed i needed something to
motivate me because otherwise it was
going to be a really slow process and i
didn't know what my
what my inspiration was going to be
and i but at the same time i didn't know
how
i was going to be performing at this
exhibition because that was a scary
thought
so little by little i started i started
skating again i got
kind of my basic trick set back
um i didn't have my pump which is
basically how you get the speed through
the transition through the radius of the
ramp i i couldn't i couldn't connect
with that the way i used to so i just
sort of resigned to i'm only going to be
able to go this high
gotcha maybe forever i don't know
because i just can't i can't push
through and get the speed and
ended up doing the demo
i mean i think i did okay i really
couldn't tell you it was all sort of it
feels like a dream now
but after that that's when i really
started working at getting my skill set
back and it took me about a year a year
because it it it was it wasn't just the
the tricks it was the confidence
that's what i wanted to ask you like the
anxiety of
like
can i do this you question everything
right it was like everything that i've
ever before no not to that level i'm
sure not at all not at all even when you
first started
i mean well you're 10 then you don't
give a [ __ ] you're bulletproof at 10. we
were when we were doing the just weeks
prior when we were doing the huck jam
shows
the loop was like a toy
we were just you know i would be doing
like
kick flips and shove it's on the deck
and then drop into a loop and go into a
routine and it was it was like none of
that we just i never considered
that it was gonna be
devastating or could be devastating
um
and then when it was
it was like
what have you been doing all this time
yeah tell me all these species change
you yeah yeah it was it was like are you
out of your mind like this this stuff is
all dangerous i mean that's
that's where my mind started to go and
then as i started develop my skills
again i that started to fade but there
were a couple times
that because i was the the side of my
pelvis that i broke was is my right leg
and that's my front leg
so
when i would be skating i'd be favoring
my back leg
unknowingly
and quite a few times i ended up just
falling backwards
um one time i got another concussion
because of that another time
my tail and my skateboard broke off as i
was going through the flat because
you're leaning that far closing that far
and i didn't realize it and so i had to
try to figure out how to compensate for
that as well and everything was just
you know my world was rocked and my
my um
confidence was was changed
but i finally got through it like a year
later and started figuring out
new tricks and and sort of
all that time was you know it was it was
formative
but it started to fade
yeah
what about the anxiety for the wild boys
crew and stuff are they like oh my god
we might have just ruined tony yeah the
next time i saw that the next time i saw
him
so go after that i mean definitely stevo
and pontius and tremaine were were
really freaked out
um
and after that every time i would do
something with jackass
they were throwing me the tamest
things that that they had
like they would send me a list of things
i was like you guys
do you want me to even stand on the
skateboard
foot one flight i don't know
yeah it was it was all like i could just
tell that the stuff they would give me
was was sort of the safer version but at
the same time i love those guys and
it's always just so fun to be around
them and i'm in i'm in the intro to the
new jackass forever
um
and i and
i got hurt doing it so you did you know
well i mean i didn't get hurt hurt but
i left with a bloody hip i was gonna say
you're not leaving a jackass set without
something right
um all right we did jump around a little
bit let's go back to the beginning so a
10 you start skating your dad says the
he supports it does is one year in the
in the president of the little league
and now what you're just off and running
from 10 is that it do you do play other
sports or are you just all in on no all
in on skateboarding uh i would go
whenever i could get a ride to the skate
park uh san diego that the
park was about 15 minutes from our house
and little did i know that as i dove
into skateboarding skateboarding was
dying as an industry quickly and all the
parks were closing
so i just got lucky that one of the last
ones was in san diego
um and that was my home away from home
like that's where i found
that's where i found my my crew that's
where
if you if it wasn't at school that's
where you found me
um
and it was just this
band of misfits and everyone found
skateboarding and so we all found each
other and and it was so fun and
i could never figure out why kids my age
didn't like it
i think it was just more that that there
was a stigma that it was it was a fad it
was a toy
and grow up
right and i'm 12. like
it's i'm still a kid
but there are there are guys at the
skate park that are
18
and i'm looking up to them because
they're some of them are pro not that it
meant they were making living at it but
they had that stature and they had the
skills so i wanted to emulate them
but it was uh
it just there was no future in it
and i wasn't didn't think i was choosing
a future this is [ __ ] just insane to
me there's no future in this sport and
then i'm sitting here and talking to the
future you're the future
i i thank god you [ __ ] quit little
league bro
thank [ __ ] god you quit little
the hardest thing for me the hardest
thing for me during that time was that
because i was so small and skinny and i
kind of developed my own way of of doing
aerials and stuff and and doing little
tricks
below the coping because i just didn't
have the strength
um or the experience to do big errors
and stuff like that that that was that
was you know dog town and z boys it was
all about style right and flow and
aerials and i was like this little pixie
kid just like reaching down and trying
to maneuver my giant board under my feet
and so
i was very much extra like outcast from
this outcast society
like we're all we're all these weirdos
that skate and then i'm the weirdo in
the weird crowd because
like that kid like you're the comedian
dude i'm telling you the honeydew bro
the the theater kids the theater kids
don't want to hang out with us that's
what i try to tell comedians all the
time like once you're like oh we're the
weirdos
once you realize like it it's us then
you're [ __ ] good right when you get
around these people you're like oh okay
this feels right yeah these lunatics
feel right yeah
yeah but that was very isolating that
was hard especially at a young age but
luckily i found a couple friends that
kind of had the same vibe and and were
the same age and felt
like the you know they were intimidated
by the other guys as well so
we found each other and and we just went
with i couldn't it was
none of that was gonna make me give it
up
it it brought me too much
for my sense of self
my sense of self
and my confidence and my identity it was
like that was it i i wanted to
skateboard forever a lot of people
didn't even make resolutions this year
and you know what i get it but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't still find a
way to shake things up whether it's by
switching up your workout routine or
going someplace new so whatever you
challenge yourself with this year
there's no better way to do it than with
a pair of raycom wireless earbuds in
your ears raycon wireless earbuds are
the best way to bring audio with you
because no matter how much you shake
things up literally no matter how much
you shake you know they won't fall out
of your ears their everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever there's
also an awareness mode for when you need
to listen to your surroundings so you
can take raycons with you wherever you
go with optimized gel tips for the
perfect in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will
not budge trust me i tell you every week
i use my raycons all the time exercise
and traveling they're the best i have
never lost one they don't fall out stay
right where they're supposed to stay all
right and they also offer eight hours of
play time and a 32 hour battery life and
they're priced just right you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds of over 48
thousand five star reviews right now
honeydew listeners can get 15 off their
raycon order at buyracon.com
honeydew that's buy ratecom.com
honeydew to save 15 percent on ray cons
buy raycon.com
honeydew today i'm excited to announce
manscape launched their ultra premium
collection believe it or not it's for
your not so private parts i'm talking
about a leveled up hygiene routine with
your favorite manly scent this is an
all-in-one skin and hair care kit for
the everyday man and covers you from
head to toe
literally manscape is trusted below the
waist now trust them with the rest join
the 4 million men worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with the
code honeydew you know we love manscaped
over here i use it all the time over
there trimming everything up and keeping
it clean you know what i'm saying and
now you can enhance your perfect
grooming routine with their ultimate
premium collection this package includes
a manscape premium deodorant no not for
your balls for your stanky armpits this
deodorant dries clear is aluminum free
and smells like their signature scent
there's hydrating body spray all right
so if you have tattoos or issues with
dry skin this spray-on lotion is
designed to keep your skin feeling
moisturized smooth and smelling fresh
there's a body wash to lather you up
with the infused aloe vera and sea salt
shower gel and there's a two in one
shampoo and conditioner to clean your
scalp with an easy one step all right
plus a free gift you get a three pack
set of lip balm that's made up with
ingredients such as vitamin e peppermint
eucalyptus oil to keep those choppers
feeling moist all of these products are
cruelty free paraben free vegan friendly
and dye free the best ingredients with a
zero compromise all right get 20 off and
free shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew and
manscape.com the power of attraction is
now in a bottle thanks to manscape now
let's get back to the do all right so
how quickly do you start um seeing a
change in your life like what age are
you approached by sponsors and and all
that like when's it really start to
shift around age
12 right when i turned 12
uh
there was an event in
in my home park at oasis skate park and
the dogtown team manager at the time
was uh brought um a couple of dogtown
pros
and she
my dad
offered all of them to stay at our house
because we lived nearby and they there
was no but like you know as a kid i
don't know any about anything understand
this there's no budget they you know
they're they're barely scraping by the
skateboard company
and so he invites them to stay at our
house like with their dog and and i was
like this is awesome like pro skater
stay in my house and then
she uh her name is denise she um gave me
one of mike smith mike smith was the pro
for dog town one of his old skateboards
and she's like well thanks a lot for
letting stay at you know i think you
have a lot of potential here's mike's
old skateboard and that was my first
sponsored
deck wow so i was loosely on dog town
for oh [ __ ] all right yeah and then
eventually i started to come into my
house they say hip-pocketed by dog town
pretty much yeah yeah flo i was on
dogtown flow all right i mean that was
it there was four people on the team but
whatever uh but then then i started to
come into my own and learn some tricks
and then they started to
give me more support in the form of
skateboards on a regular basis
um and then uh
i started to sort of rise in the ranks
and then at some point i wasn't hearing
from dogtown
uh we were unable to get skateboards we
would go straight to the the board
pressing company because it was in san
diego luckily and so we would go get
skateboards off the press that we had no
graphics and i would just cover it with
dog town stickers that was like those
are my sponsored skateboards and then at
some point we couldn't get those and it
was like i didn't understand what was
happening
uh not long after that stacy peralta
called me long distance
yeah i remember long
[Laughter]
cece bill just going a long distance
and
right yeah and then i have a big deal
and then he called and he said hey tony
i heard that um i heard dogtown went out
of business
it's news to me
but now i understand why i'm not getting
skateboards
and he said we'd like you to come up to
marina marina del rey i live in san
diego marina del rey was the hub of
dog town z boys punk rock music like
that was the
that was it that was the epicenter of
skateboarding um and you had to be
hardcore to be accepted there
he's like i want you to come up to
marina
and talk about writing for
paolo peralta the bones brigade bam um
and i was
i was scared because i didn't think i
was at that level i didn't and i didn't
think they would accept me
i mean i was excited to have stacy's
approval but
that was huge you know that's like
that's like hey i know you've been
playing with your friends on the
on the playground but we want you to
play for the bulls
yeah yeah right yeah skip all these
steps
because i believe in you yeah holy [ __ ]
and so i went up there and
it felt kind of like a tryout
and i learned uh i
the marina had a famous keyhole and i
jumped the the gap of the keyhole which
was only reserved for a few select pros
like that the only people that could do
that and i think that when stacy saw me
really going for it like that he's like
okay
well we got you
and so then i was on
paul peralta um
and uh
just
doing everything i can to to earn the
the validation of the other guys on the
team
and how old are you when you get your
first ball why don't you start talking
uh so so then i'm i'm 12 i'm running for
pal peralta
i
rise very quickly through the amateur
ranks and how are you doing that by
winning contest winning contest yeah and
learning how to skate other terrain i
was really good in my home park but then
i had to i had to figure out how to
skate other terrain because every park
was so different and they're all i mean
if you look at back at them now they're
all
built really badly
yeah compared to how parks are now right
they were built by pool manufacturers
and you were just lucky if the
transitions were
really smooth
uh marina was great um
del mar was terrible but but i think
that that became my home park have you
ever skated the cove
sure you have yeah no [ __ ] yeah that's
why i take my stepson back in the day
but the cove is like
decades past yeah this stuff we were
dealing with and even that even the cove
is old now it is definitely old yeah
yeah they have done nothing to it over
there yeah
um but so i learned to scale the terrain
i i ended up
i ended up winning the amateur series by
the time i was 14.
and the only
the the the sort of unspoken
progression from that is you're gonna
turn pro
and a couple of of the guys that i was
skating with at the time already had
already moved up to the pro ranks and
they weren't even really winning the
amateur events like i was
so if i was going to stay as an amateur
it was just more like
dude come on like you got to step up
yeah
and so one event uh
i was filling out the entry i mean this
is how i turn pro i'm filling out the
entry form to the wittier turkey shoot
that's what it's called
so it's like thanksgiving
1982-14
and
it you fill out your name your address
your sponsors and then there's a box
that says amateur in the box that says
pro
and i'm looking at it and stacy's
looking over my shoulders i'm filling it
out and i was like what do i do he goes
you know it's whatever you feel man
and then i just ticked pro and he's like
all right
there it is that was it i was pro at the
turkey bowl at the at the turkey shoot
starting to shoot turkeys ended up
getting fourth place first contest
um which felt amazing
uh i was out of the money though 150
bucks first place hundred second fifty
third
almost all you get is fourth i got four
yeah
but that was i mean that was a good
introduction and also it wasn't at my
home park so i felt pretty good about it
so
look i know the the skater the punk rock
world
all of this
you're a kid
you have no idea about business and all
this is sort of new too like skating's
you said it was pretty much dead and now
it's coming back in this way where
you're involved in it
how are you just doing what the [ __ ]
feels good and right or are you
early on starting to have a business
mind about the sport as well
no i had no business nothing just being
i just wanted to learn tricks that's all
i cared about so even if i was winning
an event
or even if i went to an event i did well
the next day i was at the park trying to
learn a new trick right that was in fact
in fact if anything this the
competitions were stifling because i had
to be conservative in my skating
because you had to stay on
and then once i was released from that i
could go try whatever i wanted and bail
all day and figure out some new moves
got it
all right so what age then do you really
start to see things shift big time
uh i would say when when i was about 16
17
we started making
significant money
for anyone or anyone our age so as a dad
you look at your kids when they are 16
or 70. can you imagine them being in
right now even having to deal with any
of the stuff you have to deal with isn't
that crazy you're a child but also
but there was no
no one had been through that we didn't
have anyone to emulate or to
to learn from stacy was was helping us
with that
but all of a sudden we were just
none of us like like the bones brigade
especially
cab mcgill lance mountain tommy guerrero
uh rodney mullen none of us got into
skateboarding to be rich or famous right
and suddenly we are in a sense
rich and famous and it's like
we didn't ask for this we just want to
skate and it was weird to have people
asking for your autograph or
you know showing up to your hotel and it
was just like
what what is this
and and so when people get into other
sports or entertainment industries
that's sometimes the goal many times
that's the goal
right and so when they get it they're
they're all about it
we weren't all about it we were just
awkward so that was a weird thing to
figure out stacy definitely helped me
with it because there would be kids
standing there
at an event staring at me holding a
skateboard with my name on it
and i don't know what to do
what do you want from me yeah
i'm awkward in my own skin i'm only 17.
i'm trying to figure out like
how to talk to girls i don't i got
i don't know and so finally he's like
hey man go
just go talk to them
like they're excited to see you
he came to see you you just go you know
they know who you are yeah like like
break out of your own comfort zone and
go and and
that helped me a lot and i and i think i
learned it even more so having my own
kids and seeing them interact with
people to hook up to and and knowing how
it can affect them either
positively or negatively and
and and also having my own interactions
with pros growing up that you know i had
one pro spit on me no yeah and then i
had and then another one like hand me a
sticker
guy [ __ ] spit on you yeah yeah those
are in the days of punk rock and like i
said i was a scrappy little kid and was
like i mean
you want to say who it was
it's it's it's it's well-known it's well
known and i don't like you know he's
small on hard times and i don't wanna
i'm not trying to like i don't i don't
harbor that it's just it's something
that i live through but also it's the
70s like
we were bullied
you know what i mean that we didn't we
didn't know that at the time or have
resources for it we just got picked on
well so i want to ask you that because
skating is definitely punk rock and
how do you as tony hawk juggle
you know once you become tony hawk now
you're probably a sellout now you're not
cool and now you gotta keep proving
yourself to the young punk rock
generation the entire time which you
[ __ ] definitely have but how does it
shift from being one of
us to now you're not one of them in
their eyes
like what is that like
it's uh
well i think that because i grew up with
all of that
all of that flack
and and all the
all the haters so to speak
once i got to a point where
yes i i had i mean i kind of went
through a few phases of success so in
the 80s there was this high success
until around 1989 and then it was all
faded away we weren't getting offers
from from non-endemic sponsors so i
wasn't getting offers from
mcdonald's or jeep or whatever it was
because that skateboarding hadn't broken
that glass ceiling
yet
but once it came
back around in the late 90s
that's when things got really big and
serious and there were big sponsor
dollars happening so
i already
had lived a life where people were like
people were giving me a hard time for my
style
because they're like he's just a robot
he does circus tricks he spins his board
whatever
and
that's fine if that's how you see me but
but that was my motivation but at some
point i learned sort of all the other
elements of of what to do on a
skateboard where they couldn't really
say those things anymore you know it was
yeah that was sort of my reply to them i
was like well okay i can do this too
but i choose to focus on tricks and then
when when things came back around in the
90s and and there were big sponsorships
people were like oh you just sell out
and i was like dude i
i'm doing this for all the same reasons
i did it for no money five years ago
right
for forever forever yeah i mean i did it
you know i was trying to raise a family
paycheck to paycheck
doing demos and parking lots three a day
for 100 bucks
risking my neck yeah and
and whatever and i don't i'm not trying
to
i'm not i'm not trying to just highlight
that but that that's the reality of it
and so when we came back around and was
like hey mcdonald's wants to pay you
hell yeah i was eating mcdonald's
back then
eating it now yeah you know like i lived
on subway
i lived on subway for two summers
yeah for real i know now i'm getting
deals with subway like it's amazing
and so it's not i haven't i haven't um
i haven't traded my values in for the
success
it's it's just who i am
and and so at some point
that was that's how i got through it
it's just like well i know what the
reasons are i know what my beliefs are
and this is who i am
and and if you don't like it if you
think that's a sellout then that's on
you
and maybe if you had the success and you
got offered a deal from subway you could
turn it down yeah i'm trying to feed my
family yeah trying to pay literally and
ride my skateboard because this is what
like all of this is incidental to riding
my skateboard that's it
it's hard for other people to understand
that when you're in it like it all this
is cool yeah but it starts and in those
slow days i was i was doing odd jobs
like yeah talk to me about you said uh
the sponsorships went away you said 89
it got a little around nine i say 91 was
sort of when everything dropped so what
does tony hawk if if you're not skating
what do you do to bring in money
um i had a uh well i borrowed money from
my parents you really did yeah i
borrowed i think i brought four thousand
dollars from them to buy an editing
day
and the editing bay i bought i bought on
at a consignment shop it was already
outdated by the time i bought it but
it's all i could afford right so i
bought and and video
nerds will like this i bought
three three-quarter tape decks
so that i could have an i used to be a
pa so i got another
source going into a final output
and then i had a video toaster and the
video toaster was one of the first
consumer video editing
gear it did not editing just um effects
and so i started doing that and i
started making
i i became an editor for hire for other
skate companies so i actually did i put
together a few skate videos during that
time
but
as as it came to be the decks i bought
were
terrible
and they kept eating tapes
and there was a moment where
all i'm trying to do is get this
thousand dollars i got offered to edit
this video yeah that's what that that
will that will pay the mortgage and
they'll get me by another month
and i'm in my i
converted one part of the garage to a
little editing bay so i'd walk through
like all of our [ __ ] and then just like
sit there through the night doing stuff
and
i just had a few things to cut
and the tape just locked up and broke
the tape and then the machine froze
and i'm lost
it's done like this does no digital back
up there's no digital backup
physical tape
and i had i had taped
the
tape back together a few times like i
wasn't above that that has worked for me
in the past
this machine is frozen up it's not
working anymore
and i just saw everything ending right
then and i just laid i just put my head
down on the desk started bawling did you
really yeah cause i was like i don't i
don't know what to do this was this was
my only link
to making a living right now
and
it it's done
um
i ended up
i'm living in fall only from fallbrook
is
but fallbrook was i i moved there so i
could have room to build ramps my ramps
are all falling apart because i can't
afford to keep them up we can barely
afford to live there now i've got two
mortgages
i'm renting the other place
i called the consignment shop when they
opened at 9am they're in burbank
and i said i said oh um this tape thing
froze up he's like well come up here
we'll reset i go can you just tell me
how to reset it he's like no you just
gotta you gotta come up here you gotta
come here they think i'm in l.a i'm like
so i drive like three hours
to this consignment shop in burbank who
they don't give a [ __ ] about me like
they're they're just annoyed that i'm
even calling them about i mean they
don't they're not giving any warranties
out right yeah you know what i mean
they're just like
so i come in
the guy
pulls two screws off the back
opens it up hits a reset button
six hour round trip
but i was back in business
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that's the easiest i'll never
forget looking at him i was like you
could have told me how to do that
because yeah but we don't want people
taking these apart i'm like you don't
these aren't even under your warranty
like yeah you know you don't it's
just these
there's a couch over there this thing
was used when i bought it so
but then i learned how to reset the tape
or reset the player
drawback did the thing but but then
realized quickly that how long are you
editing how long is this little um it
was
off and on for about a year damn that's
a that's a long time to be out of what
you'd love in your passion i was still
skating i mean i was i was not making
money i was hustling
sometimes
i would be hired as a consultant
sometimes for shoes because because at
this point
i'm 24.
that's supposedly too old to be skating
for a living is that right that's where
that's the number yeah
i mean at that time
and so but my name was out there so for
instance um
i want to say it was a mountain dew
commercial they said hey we want to hire
you to
uh get other skaters
and to maybe build a ram for this shoot
like yes please
okay we'll pay you 500 bucks
okay
and give you a hundred dollars to build
a little jump ramp for this thing which
is awesome
so i built a jump ramp borrowed
someone's truck
drove it to hollywood
it actually flew out of them
this is not a joke we built the jump
ramp barely put in this guy's truck that
luckily i got to borrow and it the wind
caught it it blew up
crashed broke one piece of it completely
off
and i was like dude
so managed to put it back in get it to
the set and and put like a sheet of
metal over where it was missing and it
worked
and that was my 500 bucks
it was just stuff like that like it was
it you know it was it was very much
paycheck to paycheck but
but i wanted to be in skateboarding so i
was doing everything i could to just be
make myself out there
to get to get
work i i read a lot and and people say
this too um
a big part of success is staying in the
game
and you even though you were weren't in
in you still managed to stay in and stay
present and stay in that game even
though you're over here
trying to edit and do everything you can
to pay bills and [ __ ] so i i think that
is i really believe that's a huge part
of it because at any moment you could
have stepped out and that's it
once you sever that that's it yeah and
and it's funny because
looking back at those times yeah they
were trying but i don't think of them as
like
the most depressing
it was just more that these were the
things i was to go through and these
were my learning
phases
and uh i learned a lot doing that and
when do you see it shift and start to
rise again
uh after the probably after like the
second x games around 96.
yeah because skateboarding was kind of
back
on the radar or you're back in the
collective consciousness of
mainstream media
and it had gone through a whole
revolution
in those dark years of street skating
and tricks and
you know people didn't realize what was
possible on a skateboard and they saw
the x games like what is going on here
seriously people are you know this is
this is acrobatic and this is
crazy and this is like magicians and
then kids took to it because they're
like these guys are risking their lives
and they love it and they're doing it
for no money and
these basketball players won't even give
us the time of day
yeah
and and it was just they i feel like and
they identify with that so greatly that
kids just
boom yeah that was it how were you when
you had your first board
first pro model yeah 14.
what's that like to ride your first pro
model
uh
it fourteen or nineth grade
yeah it's weird it's it um
what's it like it it's it's putting
extra pressure on yourself that you
better deserve it
i remember
yeah i mean your boards and how many
different boards have you had over the
years how many different versions
uh
tons of tons yeah
would you have a favorite to ride still
uh my my current shave i've been riding
for probably like 10 years yeah the same
one yeah
yeah so
as a dad now like do all of your kids
skate
they do yeah they do yeah my daughter is
she shied away from it in recent years
but um all the all the boys yeah
all right so here's what i mean you've
done so many things tv movies all of it
like
i know you have to get out of here and i
want to respect your time and everything
so i'm going to ask you this last
question here after everything we've
talked about today the things you've
been through the fears the insecurities
the anxiety
14 is your own [ __ ] i mean it's
insane have your own board so what
advice
would you tell
16 year old tony hawk
uh
what advice um work on your
relationships
i mean that was definitely the biggest
challenge in my life and something that
i had to come to terms with
in a very serious way
um about 10 years ago and and trying to
figure out
why i couldn't make relationships work
you know more like intimacy issues and
um
i did a lot of work on it and and leaned
into getting help
i think i would tell myself my 16 year
old self go get help
that's great that's great advice
dude thank you this is a dream come true
thank you for doing this um again if
you'd like to promote anything
definitely hawk versus wolf your
documentary coming up um yeah that's
that's kind of where we're at i'm gonna
i don't know if people are listening
europe but i'll be i'm doing a european
speaking tour
um in uh july and early august what does
that entail uh i'm going to venues and
and just sort of telling my story i've
done a lot of speaking gigs through the
years usually for
conferences or corporate events um but
this is just
mine only so uh i'll be telling stories
and
you know just sort of my
my career arc and funny anecdotes and i
promise i'm funny
this has been great man thank you thank
you so much real
as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you